з drude ворожите, подзвоніть мені, якщо ви цього не зробите
Vale Dona Я думаю, що це супер плачучий нейрорекорд
без будь-якого переговорного процесу задоволення
Сандра Енфіадо брокер У мене є мобільний телефон
це валерія, передай і дзвони
The
у нас є наступне до третього до
коли можна бесса і вибачте доктора
bullet так, я не хочу, щоб ти казав мені, котра година
навчиться брехати цю історію
не було грамів як і коли вона
може це не я
Я прийшов у ту чергу, яку вони взяли
[Пісня]
а
так тепер для мене
привіт, кузино, щоб забронювати що-небудь у вас
все добре
привіт, і вона змінила вже тисячі переглядів
води, потім два три і один
як справи